le quiero preguntar a enric un poco cómo
entender la pérdida de valérie pécresse
que es una candidata conservadora que al
inicio de la campaña se planteaba como
la principal candidata o la principal
rival de manuel ma con sin embargo
durante la campaña electoral se desinfló
y los dos ultraderechistas lepén y se la
superaron en las votaciones al igual que
la izquierdista mencionó a qué se debe
esta derrota de pecas si es un resultado
catastrófico debemos recordar que en
2017 el candidato de los republicanos
logró el 20 por ciento de los votos hoy
5 por ciento y en el parlamento es la
principal fuerza de oposición
los republicanos entonces el panorama
político va a cambiar por este declive
de los republicanos que sigue el declive
del partido socialista y como su
periodista a lograrlo dijo hay un
problema de sobrevivencia de estos dos
partidos políticos y como usted lo dijo
hay más diferencia
este año entre marco y lópez pero hay
más reservas de voto para lope en
comparación con hace cinco años y es
decir que cuando valérie pécresse dice
que ella va a votar a favor de macro eso
no cambia muchas cosas porque primero va
a haber divisiones en su campo y porque
segundo hay poca gente que votó para
ello entonces es una tal vez el elemento
fundamental de esta noche de esta
elección es el declive
tal vez definitivo de los dos grandes
partidos políticos en la historia de la
quinta república los republicanos la red
de derecha liberal y el partido
socialista